let's keep talking a little bit about
foreign policy one other joe biden
foreign policy uh
note joe biden did have a call phone
call with russian president vladimir
putin
and i'm going to say this in a
particular way but i'm not
necessarily attaching value judgment to
it joe biden
stood up to vladimir putin during this
phone call in a way that donald trump
never did
now that doesn't mean we're cheering for
joe biden to go to war with russia we're
not
this doesn't mean we are cheering for
joe biden to be unnecessarily
hostile or adversarial with vladimir
putin
um this is it almost shouldn't even be a
big deal that this is how joe biden
managed the phone call with vladimir
putin it's just not the way donald trump
operated
donald trump was enamored by and
deferred to
various authoritarian leaders around the
world we now have a readout from the
white house and we will look at it
together this was released yesterday
it reads president joseph r biden jr
spoke today with president vladimir
putin of russia
they discussed a number of regional and
global issues including the intent of
the united states and russia
to pursue a strategic stability dialogue
on a range of armed
arms control and emerging security
issues building on the
extension of the new start treaty
president biden also made clear that the
united states will
act firmly in defense of its national
natural national
interests in response to russia's
actions such as cyber intrusions
and election interference specifically
referring to
the cyber intrusions that we know russia
was involved in recently
and the election interference that we
know russia attempted recently
the readout goes on to say president
biden emphasized the united states
unwavering commitment
to ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity the president voiced our
concerns over the sudden russian
military buildup in occupied crimea
on ukraine's borders and called on
russia to de-escalate
tensions president biden reaffirmed his
goal
of building a stable and predictable
relationship with russia
consistent with u.s interests and
proposed a summit meeting
in a third country in the coming months
uh
this is you know it's not a big deal
in that this is how most presidents deal
with other adversaries who we know
have geopolitical ambitions that may be
at a conflict with those of the united
states
it's not about picking a side it's
we have countries nation states exist
we have multinational collaboration
we have treaties we have agreements and
we expect
our leaders to look out for the best
interests of our country
that's it and that's already more than
donald trump ever did
biden released the content of the call
uh nobody ate the notes i mean remember
when i'm talking about that
there was the story of um omarosa
who uh said that she walked in on donald
trump
eating paper after a meeting with
michael cohen
in what she believed was an effort to
destroy sensitive information
okay that that's the reference with
eating paper um
unlike the previous administration the
fact that we have this readout
also means that the entire transcript of
this call is available
to intelligence members that have the
appropriate clearance and access
as opposed to never being created as was
the case with some of donald trump's
conversations with
vladimir putin so everything is being
managed in a completely different way
it's not about we want war with russia
it's not about militarism
we just want a president that's firm and
isn't obviously
railroaded by every authoritarian
autocrat that he talks to and seems
taken with remember trump
displeased with angela merkel uh
displeased with
uh for a period of time theresa may
displeased with justin trudeau
and emmanuel macron are traditional
allies but
taken by putin's shows of strength
um impressed by kim jong-un
um it's it was very very backwards and
so this is
without nobody's rallying for war you
know there's going to be some on
the revolutionary left who will
say that a commentary like mine
is beating drums of war against russia
or arguing for hostility we're not doing
any of those things it's simply a
president
who is able to be cordial but firm
in a phone call with another world
leader it's a president who's not
so impressed with himself that he's even
having the conversation
and is just able to be railroaded and
bamboozled by anyone it's just a
president who understands geopolitics
and understands how you deal with these
situations so
i think there's a lot of good signs here
of joe biden in the last 24 hours
firm with putin in a phone call saying
we are getting out of afghanistan there
is a date
certain we're getting out on september
11 2021.
these are good signs geopolitically in
terms of foreign policy from joe biden
doesn't mean he's going to do everything
right doesn't mean we'll agree with
everything he does but certainly
much of the fear-mongering from uh from
the right and some on the left as well
about joe biden's going to invade
everybody
and expand our presence and it does not
seem to be what he's doing for the time
being and that's a good thing i'm glad
to see that
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at dpakman
many so-called healthy snacks
don't taste that great they don't fill
you up they don't satisfy a craving
which is why you should check out our
sponsor monk pack
and their keto nut and seed bars
delicious sweet snacks with only a gram
of sugar or less
two to three grams of net carbs and just
150 calories perfect for the
keto or low carb diet or anybody who
just generally tries to eat a low sugar
diet
like me i love the monk pack keto nut
and seed bars
just a great balance of sweet and salty
soft and chewy but with a nice
crunch from the nuts and seeds you can
get
great flavors like caramel not caramel
come on guys
caramel sea salt sea salt dark chocolate
peanut butter dark chocolate that's my
personal favorite they'll give you
all of your money back if you don't love
it go to monkpack.com the link is down
below and you'll get 20
off any of their products when you use
the coupon code
pacman